[Music]
good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight hope you had a great 4th of July
while you were celebrating the birth of
our country some on the Left were bro
moaning it's very existence vox.com
commemorated Independence Day with a
piece entitled three reasons the
American Revolution was a mistake
progressives despise Donald Trump so
much they've begun to dislike the
country that elected him hate has
clouded their vision and distorted their
values completely for generations for
example liberals championed free speech
and privacy and due process now they
lead the charge against civil liberties
and all who dare to defend them Alan
Dershowitz has been a liberal icon for
50 years a stalwart defender of civil
liberties just this morning he was
denounced by the left as an agent of the
Kremlin of Vladimir Putin himself his
crime suggesting that the president
might also be protected by the Bill of
Rights just like everybody else not
allowed professor Dershowitz joins us in
just a minute to explain what happened
to him meanwhile signs of growing
extremism in this country on the Left
are everywhere just yesterday a
Congolese immigrant shut down the Statue
of Liberty our Statue of Liberty to
protest the Trump administration's
immigration policies the left applauded
that but take three steps back and think
about what you're watching right here
Congo is a war ravaged hellscape a
country noted for mass rape and
cannibalism imagine escaping a country
like that and being welcomed in our
country the United States you'd be
grateful wouldn't you many Congolese are
grateful this person is not grateful at
all she took over one of our monuments
to scream about how racist we are and
progressives support her they have gone
insane on MSNBC New York Times columnist
Michelle Goldberg explained that 81 year
old Justice Anthony Kennedy somehow
betrayed America by daring to retire
from the Supreme Court watch this this
is Kennedy betraying the country the
Democrats could have done very little so
things are 30 years betraying the
cobbler
the mean people in that because there's
a boy it makes you Tony
retiring at 81 is betrayal because it's
inconvenient
to their political plans and then
there's this yet more casual racism from
MSNBC notice how it's just assumed that
there's something distasteful or even
immoral about hiring someone of a
specific race and gender the left used
to believe in judging people on the
content of their character not on the
color of their skin that seems like
ancient history now watch for the
president it's gonna be all about the
personal connection who he feels
comfortable with in the moment so you're
saying he's gonna pick the man
90% of Donald Trump's elections for US
attorneys and federal judges were white
men what happened to liberals well a lot
of things one they lost power and that
drove them off the deep end they plan to
get their power back no matter what it
takes a new book by Professor David
Farris is called it's time to fight
dirty and it explains how the Left plans
to do it here's the summary of the book
from Politico quote grant statehood to
DC in Puerto Rico and Break California
into seven with the goal of adding 16
new Democrats to the Senate expand the
Supreme Court and the federal courts
packing them with liberal judges move to
multi-member House districts to rollback
the effects of partisan gerrymandering
pass a new Voting Rights Act including
nationwide automatic voter registration
felon enfranchisement and an end to
voter ID laws grant citizenship to
millions of undocumented immigrants
creating a host of new democratic
leaning voters as Ferris puts it in the
book quote Republicans have always
feared that immigration would change the
character of American society Democrats
should reward them with their very worst
nightmare
remember that paragraph it is the
blueprint for what we're about to see
they're gonna tell you it's about civil
rights or some other principle they
pretend to care about but they're lying
it's about seizing power and holding it
that's their only aim they're deadly
serious about it well you were grilling
in the backyard last night they are
plotting in effect a coup